-Great to see you in person.
-Oh, it's so good
to see you again, yeah.
-It's great to be here.
You're here.
You're in New York City.
You got a live crowd right here.
-Yeah.
It's so good
to have people back, right?
-Do you love New York City
when you come visit?
-Love it.
Absolutely enjoy coming back.
Have such a blast here.
-Yeah.
Did you ever spend
a lot of time here or no?
-I -- I first came here
when I was 18.
I was traveling
around America by bus.
And I -- first time
I got to New York,
I had like $50 left.
I had, like, zero money,
and I was like,
"What am I gonna do?"
So, I thought the last thing
I can do with that money is
go up -- go up the Eiffel Tower.
-Oh, the Empire --
-No, not the Eiffel Tower.
That's in Paris.
[ Laughter ]
The Empire State Building.
-50 bucks --
-Just testing you guys there.
-50 bucks, JetBlue
can get you there.
I mean...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, but then you got to pay --
then you got to pay for it,
then go up.
Yeah.
-And then,
so I got to the top of
the Empire State Building,
right?
Getting it right.
-So you had 50 bucks.
You go, "I'm gonna go..."
-Nothing left.
And I thought...
-Get a cab, go do it.
-Go check it out.
I go to the top,
I saw Val Kilmer up there.
Like,
"What's he doing up there?"
I just thought,
"This is -- This is crazy."
So, Val Kilmer was on top
of the Empire State Building.
-By himself?
-Yeah.
Not quite sure what he was
doing, up there, but I mean --
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
What was he -- was he just
enjoying the views?
-I think he was.
I should have spoken to him.
I should've said something.
-You didn't say anything
to Val Kilmer?
-Oh, no, no.
Or bought him a hot dog
or something, I don't know.
-He's a --
He's the funniest guy.
He's the nicest guy.
He's Batman.
-He is Batman, right.
-Yes, he was Batman, yeah.
-Certainly a lot better than
the Batmans we saw before.
-Well, yeah --
-I mean, they were good --
-But you have a little history
of being Batman.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You were in a show called
"Batman Live."
-That's right, yeah.
A couple years ago, I --
-This is Sam in --
-Geez.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Now, what --
What was "Batman Live"?
Was it -- Was it a musical?
-That was --
It's a -- It's a stage show.
It's like a Cirque show.
And we went
all around the world.
We kinda --
We did the Staples Center,
we did Vegas, we did
all around the world, yeah.
-This is before
"Outlander," obviously.
-Before, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I mean, can we -- can we --
-I'm not sure if Batman's
ever worn a kilt, has he?
Probably a bit weird, right?
-No, yeah, you never know.
Probably be --
But it'd be interesting.
A Batman in a kilt, I would do.
-Right.
-Would you ever do a Batman,
if they asked you to do --
-Oh, my God.
-You have the jaw line.
-I mean --
[ Laughter ]
Thank you very much.
I mean your jaw's --
Oh, yes, come on.
-This is --
-Wow, all right.
-This is real.
-Do I get to do it?
-Yeah.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
Where am I looking?
-Look over at 1.
-Oh, I got it,
I got it, I got it.
[ Dark music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-Where did that music come from?
Okay, okay.
[ Clears throat ]
"I am Batman."
-Wow!
That's actually fantastic!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I --
[ Dark music plays ]
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
-"I need a sidekick."
-What?
-"Do you need one that looks
and talks just like you?"
-"Yeah."
-"Then I'm right here."
-"There you are."
-"I'm Batman."
-"Ah, I'm Batman."
-"Cool."
[ Applause ]
-Dude, Batman and Batman,
would be --
that would be the next --
-That's the next movie, right?
-Before we get into "Outlander,"
I want to congratulate you.
Before,
we've talked about your whiskey.
This is a sassenach?
-Yes.
-Is how you pronounce it.
-That's right.
-Thank you.
And, congrats,
'cause you made this whiskey,
and you're Scottish, and you go,
"Yeah, I'm gonna
make a whiskey,"
and you don't mess around.
-Right, right.
-You ended up winning
all these awards for it.
I go, "That's fantastic.
Congratulations."
And it's all awesome.
Then you show up today.
I go, "Good to see you, Sam.
What's up?"
You go, "Got a present for you."
And I go, "Whiskey."
And I look and it's not.
It's tequila.
-Right. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Now I go, "Well, maybe he
thinks I have a problem."
-Yeah, I just keep
bringing you alcohol.
-Keep bringing me alcohol,
I go, "Oh, thank you, tequila."
And you go,
"Yeah, but it's my tequila."
-Yeah.
-You're in the tequila business.
-We are, yeah, yeah.
Randomly went to --
to Mexico to just go
to the highlands there,
and just met these guys
at El Tequileno,
and they are just
master distillers.
They are Mexico's
best-kept secret.
They're the most popular
blanco in tequila.
And we just realized --
we bonded.
Like, they love good spirits.
I'm Scottish,
we love good spirits.
-Yeah.
-And the stories are the same,
the culture,
and we decided to collaborate,
and make this amazing tequila.
-And then you made
this amazing tequila.
What is it called?
-It's called
the Sassenach Select:
El Tequileno,"
and we just won a couple of
gold medals for it, as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Another award winning --
I mean, dude, you --
-What's next, right?
-I'm so happy.
That's so cool.
-What do you want?
We'll make it.
-Yeah, what do you --
I like gin,
if you want to work on a gin.
-Oh, we could do that, yeah.
Jimmy's Gin?
-Ginny Fallon.
Yeah, go for it, you take it.
-Take the name.
Let's talk "Outlander."
-Okay, yes.
-Okay.
Season six returns on Sunday.
People cannot wait.
In fact, people --
when you're off,
they call it
"The Droughtlander."
-"Droughtlander," yeah, yeah.
-Yeah,
they really miss the show.
-Each year, the Droughtlander
gets slightly longer.
This year, the break has been
almost two years
between seasons, so --
I think we're just
testing our fans.
Like, next time,
it will be like a decade.
-No, you can't do that.
[ Laughter ]
-Just, like, pushing them.
-But, you know,
it's based off some amazing
books, amazing writing.
But the author's
only working on her --
-Diana Gabaldon --
And thank you, Diana.
She's -- She has written
this amazing series.
She's on book 10.
We're on book --
We're about to do book seven
in season seven,
so we've still got
a bit of way to go.
-Do you know how it ends?
-I do.
I do.
I know how it ends.
-See, I don't know if you're
lying to me or if you're acting.
-Ah, yeah.
-Wow, you're really --
-Yeah, no.
-You're in your Batman role
right now. I like it.
-Yeah.
She -- "I'm Batman."
No, she revealed to me --
she revealed to me the ending
a long time ago, actually, so...
-She's written the end
but she hasn't written --
-Yeah, yeah.
-It's in her head?
She knows how it ends?
-In her head
and in my e-mail chain, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-Let's hope I don't get hacked.
-Yeah, I know,
I hope you don't -- oh, my gosh.
"I'm Batman" is your password.
[ Laughter ]
-How did you know?
Oh.
-But that's wild.
All right, so what --
How can you set up
the new season for everybody?
-So, we're picking up
a short time after the end
of season five,
and Claire was assaulted.
She's kind of suffering
a lot of trauma from that.
We have the War of Independence
fast approaching,
and then, my character
meets an old adversary
in the form of Tom Christie,
so there's so many things
happening this season.
It's a shorter season, but some
of the episodes are much longer.
So it --
it really is very intense.
-Guys, get ready.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Sam Heughan in season 6
premiere of "Outlander."
Take a look.
-Tom received word
his wife had died
while we were Ardsmuir.
But you?
You were there with me,
in the prison.
I saw you.
♪♪
It's what got me through it.
You are always with me.
♪♪
Sometimes, I...
I think you're an angel, Claire.
♪♪
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
Sam Heughan right there,
everybody.
Season six of "Outlander"
premieres this Sunday on Starz,
and we're working
on our Batman movie.
We are.